well welcome back to washington d.c and
we have some breaking news this minute
in the u.s presidential election
for the first time since polls close the
democratic candidate joe biden
has taken the lead in the count
underway in the key state of
pennsylvania if
mr biden holds that lead and takes the
state
he will be the next president of the
united states the 46th
president this change from donald trump
who's led
from the beginning has come about
because a new
number of votes have been counted and
added to the total
and mr biden's lead is now you can see
uh he has 49.4 percent uh compared to
49.3 percent
uh to donald trump his lead is some 5
500 votes well let's speak to james
matthews who's following the election
uh closely for us here in washington dc
james we've been saying this was going
to happen
it has now happened what's the
significance
uh i think it puts joe biden in front
and i
frankly adam i don't think we're very
far away from uh
joe biden stepping in front of the
microphone to accept victory on
to declare victory in this election uh
donald trump was ahead in pennsylvania
it's a but because of mail-in ballots
being counted all the time
overwhelmingly in favor of joe biden
we've reached the stage where they have
overtaken the trump total
in terms of figures we will see from now
from those mail-in ballots in
pennsylvania
the trend i expect to continue because
of the democrat areas they are
coming from it is it will be a delicious
victory for joe biden
in that particular state it will take
him to 273
he needs to reach 270 so that's enough
to get into the white house but he is
pennsylvania man of course from scranton
pennsylvania that's how he characterized
this election scranton versus park
avenue
to have one in pennsylvania which donald
trump tried so hard
to defend uh will be good for joe biden
very significant for what should be
his presidency and let's be clear about
this if
joe biden holds on to his lead in
pennsylvania
he will have done as a democratic
candidate what was asked of him which
was to go back
to those three rust belt states
wisconsin where you were
michigan and pennsylvania and take them
back
they were the states that hillary
clinton
lost narrowly in shock votes that's what
cost her the presidency
now joe biden's got them back that's
right the so-called blue wall that
donald trump
shattered in 2016 joe biden had to pick
up the pieces and put it back together
again
to go back into that democrat heartland
and rebuild
democrat support it appears he has done
that
it was a tough call it was a close call
mind you because in this election
it was all about the economy in places
like pennsylvania it was all about
jobs donald trump his message to
uh particular parts of pennsylvania
which rely on the natural gas
industry fracking and so on was luke
this is a man who will sell out to china
who won't be creating american jobs or
ban fracking will be bad
for your state joe biden uh said lou
there's one key issue in this election
it's coronavirus the economy is linked
to that
your future is linked to coronavirum to
grow the economy
via coronavirus i'm the man who can best
represent you
well james matthews thank you very much
indeed